ladies and gentlemen thank you for
coming to another episode with them with
Griffin and as I still haven't picked
the perfect theme song but we're in
search this is episode 7 of Rifton with
Griffin maybe this is it aha with
bourbon I want you to listen to my
podcast standing up sitting on your ass
I want your love I want to go whippin
with Griffin is holding your head you
can't believe what I just said I won't
you learn I can't keep going I'm sorry
oh well that was that hey man I keep
telling you guys if you wanted me to do
the particular song just send me the
[ __ ] I'll do it
but anyways welcome to another episode
of riffing with Griffin this is episode
7 officially episode 7 and what's going
on huh you know last week was what two
weeks ago was Thanksgiving and now here
we are and you know we're going into
Christmas and this can be annoying the
Christmas music has already started I'm
already annoyed out of my freaking mind
with all that right but you know it is
what it is
so Happy Holidays to everybody I'm
thinking that my mom and my parents
moved to Spain so I'm gonna go visit
them that which is a nightmare
let me just tell you that right now when
your parents move out of the country
it's a nightmare
I always tell people hey I'm going to
Spain to visit my mom and they're like
oh my god Spain it's gonna be so good
did you hear what I just um I'm going to
visit my mom you think that we'd go
inside saying you think it's fine no I'm
sitting on the couch and she's gonna
[ __ ] about Trump and say the same thing
over and over again you know my mom's
like dori like when I get off the plane
she like says Oh looking fat and then
she forgets that she already said that
to me so it's like you know it's like I
get called fat like for the 30 minutes
it takes to get there please love my mom
though it is fun to visit her I'm just
teasing so I'm gonna go do that but
anyway Episode seven is gonna be all
about you guys so I put it out on my
Instagram on my Twitter and I said hey
I'm gonna answer some questions and
we'll get into some things so I people
sent me a lot of great questions on
Instagram they sent me a lot of great
questions on Twitter and so let's just
talk about the stuff that people sent so
one of them is a funny inton to you at
the Clipper game I go to the games with
Adam Adam Devine from Alcoholics we go
to the games together we got tickets
together but the funniest moment is like
it was during the t-shirt toss you know
how the cheerleaders and this is the
spirit people they throw the t-shirts
into the stands so it's like him and I
are standing there trying to get to
t-shirt and I only knew this because
like one of the photographer's
on the sidelines had taken a series of
pictures but like they do the pictures
so you see these pictures Adam and I
looking up at this you know trying to
get the kind of get the t-shirt and then
the next picture so the first picture is
us looking up the next picture is I have
the thing in my hand with my hand in the
air and out it was elbowing me and my
gut those are some fun moments
another fun moment was when we thought
we were gonna be Golden State that year
they were on their 70 to win season you
know we were up by 20 in the first
quarter thinking this is it we're
finally gonna do it
Clippers are good and then like at the
end of the game when they went took the
lead Steph Curry shot this three-pointer
and I was like oh and then somebody
caught a picture of that so that was a
really funny moment at the Clipper game
favorite movie favorite movie is another
Instagram question from dis dis Sam man
1 2 3 D si ma and 1 2 3 the first one
front was from Arsenal beats Arsenal
beats these are people's weird names I
wish they would have put their actual
names I'm not tell people to do that
next time anyway my favorite movies
that's good one my favorite one favorite
movie of all time is the Godfather
that's a complete perfect masterpiece
movie if you haven't watched the
Godfather you should watch it on all
sound oldest [ __ ] but you got to watch
The Godfather it's it's just the perfect
storytelling perfect acting perfect
amount of drama and it's thrilling and
it's suspenseful and it's just a great
family story a great mafia story a great
crimine to this it's just the
Godfather's are going with the best
Violetta Godfather tried to pick all my
I like movies in categories you know
what I mean you can't just be like
what's your favorite movie it's kind of
like looking at MBA positions you can't
be like who's your favorite player of
all time if you could pick someone like
that that probably somebody great so
somebody like Michael Jordan you would
say right but then you can narrow it
down like well sure who's your favorite
point guard because you know you can
have a you know who's you who do you
think you're the best point guard versus
the best Center they don't do the same
thing so you could be like ok well
here's my top 5 I think movies are the
same way like I like the Godfather but I
also love trading places
I love ghostbusters you know all for
different reasons you know
I love the Star Wars series I put that
all together both of their originals
some of these other ones are just
bootylicious you know I liked Harry
Potter as a as a as a franchise more so
the old ones in the new ones um you know
so but the godfather that's my absolute
favorite movie all rights go to the next
one
what was your I made it moment in life
and that's from Nicole Marie okay
I made it moment what was it uh it was
actually a [ __ ] show in Phoenix I
was doing this it was just weird room
called Marley's Dan Majerle was an ex
son's basketball player and so he had
this bar and this person was running us
show out of there yeah I didn't know it
was like a ghetto-ass show that it was
cuz I was like the way they treated us
we got flown in and but anyways my mated
moment was I was coming down the
escalator to go to the to go to baggage
claim and there was a guy standing there
and he had a sign that said Eric Griffin
and I was like oh I made it
that's me I was acting crazy cuz I just
a funny story about that to another time
I remember I was I was I forgot where I
was but the driver had it you know
another time this five now I don't mean
nothing to me now right so I'm coming on
where's my dude every year they say
Griffin and I'll say oh that's me he
looked at me he was like me you ain't
Eddie Griffin I'm telling you the whole
ride from the hotel to from the airport
to the hotel was this dude telling me
how disappointed he was that I was in
Eddie Griffin he was so mad and I'm
tired I've been fight flown all night
you know me like a red-eye something I'm
just in the back of like oh sorry to
disappoint you man you know he just kept
going on and on me you a Eddie Griffin
[ __ ] I want to see Eddie Griffin told my
told my wife guess what I'm picking up
Eddie Griffin and I'm like okay well
thank you piece of [ __ ] um but that was
my immediate moment the first time I saw
that sign I thought
most memorable gig you've ever done most
memorable gig I mean if you mean
stand-up I don't know I don't really
have I mean that's a tough one
like it's like what's memorable
memorable doesn't mean the most
important just memorable I think the
first time I was in the Seattle comedy
contest and you know you hear Seattle
comedy contest and what you don't know
until you get there is it it's not
really in Seattle it's like all over the
Washington area but anyway you went to
this like Indian casino and it was the
first time I played in front of a
thousand plus people and I remember
walking out on stage and it was just I
mean a jam-packed room it just went all
the way this is a huge ballroom in this
casino and it was like so many people
just jam-packed and I would look down
that it was it took me like a couple
seconds to be like oh [ __ ] look at all
these people you know that was probably
my most memorable that was probably my
most memorable gig
here's a good one oh that one was from
Yas something I don't know guys you
gotta put your real name I'm gonna say
the names anymore [ __ ] it here's another
one what's your thoughts on Mormons deep
this is a deep what's my thoughts on
Mormons I actually have a couple of
Mormon friends to my very close kind
friends David and Kirsten
they were Mormon when I first met them I
actually met David at the Seattle
contest that's where we first started
hanging out this [ __ ] Siddiqui
fuller got arrested so we yeah that's
how we all met we met in the Seattle
contest and I remember I had to I got a
hotel room so I don't want some money at
craps at the Indian casino so I got a
hotel room cuz you had to put yourself
up it was like a three week contest and
you had to put yourself up so each week
if you got passed forward you got the
last place prize money and then you
ended up using that money to live so I'm
winning one money it's a casino was
great so I got a hotel I remember David
you know he's Mormon so he's got like 75
brothers and sisters so he you know he
just jumps into bed and he's like
putting his [ __ ] all over the place and
I'm an only child so on MySpace is like
hey what the [ __ ] are you doing and he
was like our brothers and sisters this
is what we do we share so that was a
moment where I was like okay the me let
me wrap my brain around this but anyways
he's Mormon and I went to a Mormon
service you know and I just think
religion is all like any other religion
I'm not gonna sit here and bash religion
cuz I know if you're watching right now
and you're super religious I know am i
special I made fun of Christians and
then people were like what about
everyone else it's like I know
Christians I have Christians in my
family I went to a Catholic school
I've been around Christians so that's
why I'm I could talk about it I don't
know a lot of these other things so
that's why I didn't batch anyone else
but they're all the same to me you know
but the Mormons in particular like it's
got a weird history you know it's you
know with the I just in my experience
it's just a little bit more
closed-minded than I would like to
people to be you know especially when it
comes to like accepting people it
doesn't seem like Mormons want to accept
people they're even more homophobic than
the other other freaking
religion I don't even know maybe not
more than Mullin maybe Muslims are even
more homophobic more hateful towards
gays I'm not sure but the Mormons seem
to have a real particular thing like
more gays need to be fixed and that's
such a weird mentality to have but like
I said it seems it seems to be too too
strict too structured in a way that
makes people feel like they can't do
anything else I mean feels like a
sorority more like a fraternity more
than like a religion my mom likes to go
to church and I get it she loves the
music the faith she was to feel like she
belongs she wants to sing some hymns and
she wants to hear great stories and feel
the community and and there's some good
in that there is I mean that's the
reason why religions are that's the
importance about religion just family
and structure and rules and like you
know do simple common-sense things like
love your neighbor and you know take
care of people and you know don't don't
be a bad person but the Mormons seem to
have like a weird and then anytime you
hear about these like I'm not saying all
Mormons or bigots and they have little
compounds where they're having sex with
young people I'm not saying that it but
it seems to be like the ones that do it
the most are the Mormons so when you
have something that's so connected to
that I don't know like I say I'm not I'm
sure there's some great Mormons out
there I'm sure there are I just haven't
met any so maybe send me a message be
like hey I'm a great Mormon but then
when you watch that show escaping
Mormons you know that was you know I
mean it's that you just go if there's a
whole show dedicated to people escaping
your church might be a situation you
know so not a big fan of Mormons I hope
I answered that question correctly
what is my favorite Netflix show as you
can see there's gonna be no rhyme or
reason we're gonna go from religion
right over to Netflix right now I'm
watching narcos Oh
narcos Mexico oh man loving this show
right now love it so much that one I
woke up in the morning and I'm watching
it and I just was like I need some
Mexican food it's the big thing I got
out of it I ordered Mexican Fleur I'm
just sitting here with my beans and rice
and I'm watching it you know you have to
read the show that's the only thing I
don't like I don't speak Spanish so like
reading shows is kind of annoying but
it's really good I highly recommend nark
watching the whole series and then
getting to this one narcos Mexico which
is really like a prequel to the ones
that are already on the air the ones
that already aired what about Pablo
Pablo whatever his name is
you know the original narcos all right
here's another one what was the worst
day job you ever had also worse weirdest
boss she ever had um what was the worst
I think the worst day job I ever had was
when I worked at Nutrisystem I didn't
work for long my buddy James was like
the manager when we were in high school
he had a job so he was working at
Nutrisystem and he got me a job so I was
a stock boy and I was like you know
putting all this weird food this weird
low calorie food you know you know it
would be like you know smothered greens
or you know it'd be like chicken-fried
steak but you know the low-calorie
version and I had to put it all in the
bags and then I said
I was in the stock room and I said howdy
fat people eat a lot of food and an
assistant manager with like um Eric can
we talk for a second I think we should
talk and I went to her office and she
was like you don't say the f-word okay I
was like I say [ __ ] she was like me he
said fat and I was like that's what geez
it was ridiculous so that was like the
weirdest day job I ever had I was
working at Nutrisystem just like that is
I felt like I was in the underbelly no
pun intended of the the fat world you
know the secret world of fat people you
know with all this stuff you know I need
to get some Nutrisystem with my fat ass
when I'm not talking about right see
what we got here
somebody's asking about my Clippers or
the Clippers making the playoffs yes
they are the Clippers are in first place
right now all you clipper haters Doc
Rivers should be a coach of the year
Clippers are in first place it would be
it he would need to get fired if they
don't make the playoffs if they just
have a complete collapse but right now
the Clippers are looking good they're
playing well that there's no brand names
they remind me of that Pistons team that
went to the championship not saying
we're going to the championship I'm just
saying they play well they play hard and
they're competing every single night and
you can't just come on our building and
think you're just gonna win so I love
what the Clippers are doing right now
all right if you were a girl who would
you rather bang Joe Rogan or Matt Damon
ah man this is you would think this
would be I don't know if this is a tough
one or not but if I was a girl what I
want Matt Damon or Joe Rogan Joe just
seems like a weirdo you know what I mean
I don't know what kind of love maker Joe
would be and Matt Damon seems a little
full of himself so I don't know I think
I guess I got to go with Joe huh
I could be on this podcast right as his
girlfriend all right what we got here
which of the greatest comics do you ever
revisit listen to watch again and think
about um listening to a lot of them but
for me the reason why I started doing
company was Eddie Murphy I really loved
Eddie Murphy like I remember watching
delirious and just being like dannis
dudas just
she was amazing you know so and then raw
I used to be able to I used to be able
to a new raw from beginning to end like
even the inflections in his voice or
even if he took a breath I could do it
while I was watching it so I love
thinking of going back to Eddie Murphy
and watch and even watching his movies
and stuff like that but then you have
people like I love Sinbad early early on
cuz he was clean comic but like so funny
and it was just so rare you know
sometimes I just throw on the Netflix or
like going my car they had this classic
Sirius station where it's like I'm not
sure this call but it's called like
comedy greats so it'll go like way back
I always tell every comic I say if
you're a comic you're trying to be a
comic you go listen to the that station
the serious stuff comedy greats and you
will realize how unoriginal you really
are other comics think they're so
original I'm not you know hey buddy
these guys have been doing this a long
time you know it's like you know when
you listen in to music and you know you
hear a rhythm there's a melody and you
think I have I heard this before and
then those like YouTube geeks you know
who are like those YouTube singers
they'll like sing a melody of like 50
songs with the same thing playing that's
how comedy is you know we're all saying
the same melody but we got different
words on it so yeah but I like George
Carlin list someone listening to some of
his old stuff it's great I don't know I
just
any Murphy's the one for me
alright are you going to interview
guests I am I'm gonna have guests on the
episode but I just I want you can you
guys fall in love with me first can you
just like get to know me I just I want
you to just be like oh I like listening
to me and then occasionally I'll have
some guests I don't want to rely on
guests and then it's just all about the
guests this is my podcast you know this
is my thoughts and feelings and the but
I am gonna have guests I am I'm gonna I
got some lined up and then it'll be just
like boom boom boom bunch of guest
you'll love it alright I love those
questions
another Clippers question do you think
the Clippers need to make a big trade or
don't or wait for the salary cap next
year um I think that for NBA teams to
truly be successful you have to have a
star I mean a star you gotta have that
dude you can't just do it with like
deeds like ragamuffins people there's
the haves and the have-nots you know and
you could see it on the court when you
watch when you see a really great player
the criminal it's an elitist system
that's why I love sports it's like
whoever is the best the fastest the
strongest your smartest those are the
ones that do it they'll have the best
Drive you could see it you could totally
see the difference so the Clippers are
great they have great players but they
don't have the best and we need like one
or two of those guys to win a
championship just look at the history of
the league what's been the toughest
obstacle you faced in your career so far
um the toughest obstacle I faced in my
career is probably insecurity you know
just thinking that you're not good
enough or you know that feeling that
like every time you don't work you're
like oh my god I'm never gonna work
again and just you know having a
negative attitude that's the biggest
obstacle it's just always thinking
people are against you always thinking
there's some conspiracy theory you're
like oh they don't like me because I'm
old and bad I'm not wider I'm not cute
or I'm not this or do you always talk
about what you don't think you have that
is the biggest obstacle so you know you
overcome that and you just look at what
you do have you after you have to really
look at yourself good what are your
strengths what can I do to make it why
have I made it well yeah and something's
going on I'm doing something right and
you have to like do that stuff more so
the biggest obstacle yes
just you you were always gonna be your
biggest obstacle and it sounds all
foo-foo but I'm telling you it's really
true okay when was the first time you
crushed it crushed it on stage
that's from Darren Carter the party
starter he's got a great podcast to
check him out Darren Carter the first
time I crushed on stage you know what
was the very first time I went on stage
I took a class at UCLA Extension and
then that showcase was in the belly that
what I'm sorry was in the or the
original room of the Comedy Store it was
like a seven o'clock show before the
real people and I crushed it I doubt I
got the bug from that I would the way
you said I'm saying words and that whole
this room full of people 200 plus people
are all laughing in unison because of me
- there's no better better drug than
that so it was actually very first time
I did it and I didn't know what to do
after that dowsed how was the thing I
was like okay now what you know it took
me like [ __ ]
I just get my camera sorry it took me
like so long to like really figure out
what to do but that's part of the game
that's the whole process um what was the
first video game that you became hooked
on the first video game I became hooked
on I was probably it was an NBA game
with my buddies yeah as like two sets of
buddies we would play NBA like NBA Live
or I forgot what it was originally
called but it was on like the Dreamcast
this NBA game it's at a point where we
had a draft to see who would get what
team and then we just did my buddy at
Jeff and I we just we used to play like
adding just ridiculous amount of games
on that on that thing but the NBA game
was the first game I ever I got addicted
to oh here's one of these deep questions
what's your thoughts in the hold the
white Howard situation well Dwight
Howard basketball player I'm not even
sure where he plays now I think he got
traded again but apparently Dwight
Howard had like a thing with a I don't
know what you say we can't say [ __ ]
right that's not the right word anymore
even though I just said it but a
transsexual a girly boy
I don't know apparently he had like and
then this person is trying to out him
and whatnot my feelings on it are it's
2018 and we still care about this we
still a worried about who people are
[ __ ] I mean come on
I it's a shame because everybody's got
their own personal story you know and
and and it's a world that is obviously
very secretive and very like of a strong
community because this is not something
that happens a lot you don't see
somebody like it's not a thing on the
news were like you are TMZ or something
where somebody's like outing people oh I
had sex with that brother it just
doesn't happen which is good I think you
know but you know it's a shame that he's
isn't such a he works in such a
masculine environment that he doesn't
want to deal with the ridicule from his
peers really of being dealing with that
even though I think that like that's
what the gay community needs is some
athlete some like big-time athlete used
to be like yeah I'm gay and then that's
that you know and then everybody's like
oh because after a while you just be
like oh man cuz he'd be so good and what
can people say you know I mean and then
for after basketball I think it would be
great for him
if he just came in cuz what if he just
came out was like yeah you know I've
tried it a couple times I've dated a few
is you know I miss my business it's none
of your business
can we talk about basketball and I think
that would defuse the whole thing but I
mean Dan we live in such a world where
we have to like identify with people's
sexuality to to be okay with them it's
like Shawn Mendes right now he's on all
over the place talking about I am not
gay I'm not I'm not I'm not as like dust
protest too much right but he feels he
feels trapped he feels like he has to be
in this situation out and let people
know I mean is it for his fans like you
know all the girls that fantasize about
him does he think that oh they're not
gonna like him anymore or is it because
for his family like what is his
motivation what was Shawn Mendes his
motivation to be so adamant about it I
mean that's the pressures from society I
mean the fact that we're still asking
about it the fact that we're still
talking about that's what we have to
remove as if it's not okay if he was so
he feels so strongly that he has to say
that and that's how I feel about the
white Howard I mean I get like him being
in a locker room when I get him without
a bunch of masculine men but you got to
think that there's probably 25% or more
of the NBA athletes are gay I mean how
is it how is it you think but there's
this weird association that we'll know
because if you're
masculine athlete there's no way you
could be gay that's just not true that's
just there's no science behind that you
know so I I would feel bad if this but
see we don't know the behind the scenes
that I do I how a situation like was
like did they have some bad breakup or
like you know was he treating her bad
because you know you know he just was
being like you know I want you telling
nobody or did he promise things and we
don't know what was going on behind the
scenes to make this person wanna be like
I'm telling the world but I think he
should jump ahead of it at this point
look his career is almost over anyway
you know he did he did what he did is is
done now he should just come out and be
like yes I did that I get you know maybe
this is just my thoughts I think that
embrace that community and then move on
and be like because he would be like but
gays have a lot of money
upwardly mobile community there's many
examples of this where you know people
look looking so I feel like Dwight
Howard could be like Lance Bass like
Lance Bass he was gay he was gay when he
was in in snake I bet you they all knew
everybody noon didn't matter but for the
image and the persona of a boyband you
needed everybody to be straight and
girls ended to love him as soon as that
[ __ ] was over Lance Bass was like okay
we don't we done hello I'm out everybody
so and he's been happier for it you he's
married now so I'm at the Clipper game
the other day
funny story about that real fast they
wanted to put Lance Bass and his husband
or boyfriend think it's his husband on
the jumbotron right and so this young
black kid who works for the Clippers he
comes over and he like he comes over
today when he's like which one of y'all
was Lance and I was sitting behind him
and I was like how dare you how do you
you don't know who Lance Bass is you
know it just was like it so it it's
something I wanted the whole section is
when the kid walked away I wanted
everybody to go bye-bye but you know he
didn't work out like that
but Lance is a cool dude I was on his
show yeah like a radio show and I've
been on his show but anyway my point is
you know he did what he needed to do you
know for the business it was a business
decision and I think that's totally okay
cuz you don't want to because one
there's something about when you come
out is gay all of a sudden now you
become the gay whatever you are like if
you're a plumber and you're just a
plumber but if you say you're gay all of
a sudden you're the gay plumber or
you're the gay basketball player the gay
boyband guy the gay singer the gay comic
and you think nobody wants that you just
wanna be you so I understand Dwight
Howard if this is true why is secretive
and all these things are going on but
eventually hopefully he will he could
have the courage or the whatever just to
be like hey this is me this is who I am
and [ __ ] you off you don't like it I got
a hundred million dollars in the banks
or whatever so you know I mean but
everybody has their own journey and
people make their own choice at their
own time and it should be their choice
so you know I hope that that situation
works resolves itself I hope it's not I
hope he wasn't being a dick I hope he
wasn't like really treat mistreating
this person cuz then you know he gets
what he deserves
you know all right let's see oh okay
well that's all the Instagram questions
let me see me grab a couple Twitter
questions and then we'll get out of here
y'all um let's see any chance of a
Montez spin-off series no well I don't
know there's probably a slim chance but
you know it's like how many central
homes it you know what I mean it's you
the guys were young they didn't know any
better they probably signed it
originally a bad deal and so they don't
you know they don't really they wouldn't
really own it it wouldn't be something
they could do whatever they wanted to do
it they would have to deal with Comedy
Central so nobody wants to do that
could I see myself working with the guys
from our cojones again yes I could I
would love to work with the boys again I
always tell them it don't even matter
they don't gotta be on Comedy Central
they can go to NBC CBS whatever and be
like hey we work in an office and then
everybody that watches the show would be
like oh man it's workaholics again but
you know they it they're the brand you
know I mean they're like Three Stooges I
love those guys you're in charge of the
next Big Brother all-star season who is
your cast oh my god this is such a great
question who would I want to be on Big
Brother
I would want ariana grande she needs to
be on there right LeBron James oh yeah
it wouldn't it be great Wendy Williams
she got to be on Celebrity Big Brother I
would like to see her in there cuz she
would just be talking [ __ ] and causing
conflict split Pete Davidson in there
too just to see if they got back
together right see how many tattoos they
would get while they're in the Big
Brother house who also want to see there
I would love to see Sebastian Sebastian
Maniscalco he's a comic super funny
comic he would be hilarious and a big
brother house Chris D'Elia would be
hilarious in the Big Brother house you
know I loved his Z Chris in a big
Michelle Obama would be great in a Big
Brother house so LeBron Michelle Obama
ariana grande Pete Davidson Chris D'Elia
Joe Rogan who else would I'm on the Big
Brother house somebody from boys to men
I don't care who because I just want
somebody singing in the shower you know
it is a bunch of others um let's see
what else we got here if acting career
develops to the point where you can turn
down roles or quit doing stand-up what
would be your Sophie's Choice this is a
great one this would be my last one guys
it's gonna be the last question if I had
to choose between stand-up or acting
what would I choose well first I want to
say hopefully I never have to make this
choice because that would be tough I
really love doing stand-up
I'm talking about like I have had some
really really shitty days I've had some
really shitty experiences happened in my
life I've had some things and then I can
go to the stage and I can be okay I
really can I can go and just
like let out this pain and suffering and
and and commiserate with the audience
they don't know you know cuz I imagine
like you're having a bad day and you
still have to go to work and your job is
to make people laugh to make people
happy I think the act of that is what is
the healing you know so I will after are
sitting all this it would obviously be
stand up I would choose stand up I would
just hope I wouldn't have to because I
also love acting I just love because I'm
acting on I'm already a good stand-up is
acting you know you're up there we're a
heightened version of ourselves and it's
just there's nothing like it any kind of
performance art if you've never done it
I really recommend you go out and doing
that but anyways that was Episode seven
of riffing with Griffin you know what
because of talking about this actually
I'm gonna tell you yeah but so eight and
I promise this was gonna be the episode
eight is gonna be how to become a comic
I'm gonna tell you all the ins and outs
of writing stand-up about trying to you
know to find places to perform what what
are my thoughts and about you know
writing a joke and you know how to start
doing it and how to continue it and so I
want to talk about stand-up on my next
podcast and then after that we're gonna
start having some gas but anyways I
really appreciate all your support and
love on Soundcloud iTunes subscribe to
my youtube channel please keep watching
keep listening and I'm gonna keep doing
it you know whether you if whoever's
there or not I'm gonna keep doing
because this is turning into a some
great therapeutic experience to sharing
all my stories and my thoughts with you
guys so thanks again once again for
listening to with Anna Griffin thank you
and I will see you soon